all right jenny what do you got for me
tonight hi
can you hear me good
yeah you're good can i be yeah okay um
so a question
i've been with my boyfriend since 2006.
um i'm 34 by the way and he's 35
i we pay 50 50 on everything um
household
our utilities rant everything
um it didn't really bother me until i
started seeing your content and i'm
wondering am i doing the wrong thing
well i mean you guys live together
yes
and you i mean i'm guessing you make
about the same income because you say 50
50 here in the private message so you
guys make about the same um
i i think he makes a little bit more
than me
okay and
why does it start to bother you now
uh it doesn't bother me i just listening
to your um you know your info and
everything that the man supposed to lead
he's supposed to pay for everything and
i felt that i was probably doing things
wrong because i go 50 50 on everything
well
when i say that i mean i'm talking about
like a conventional type of relationship
where you're living together and yeah
and you're raising kids
right because you know typically in that
sort of environment like do you guys
have kids
yes uh my son just turned seven a few
days ago
okay so it's just the one
okay so he's in school you guys both go
to work so you're not a stay-at-home mom
there's no need for you to be a
stay-at-home mom at this time no but i i
would love to though
yeah well
i mean the kid's seven like what are you
gonna do during the day while while he's
at school right
so
i mean like when i'm making that point
that you know men lead and they take
care of things it's generally speaking
because she's at home making babies for
him she's making babies she's making the
house at home she's making the meals you
know she's a compliment to his life
like that sort of stuff um when
you get into the new age you know
progressive sort of stuff where like
you're working a job and he's working a
job full-time and you kind of come home
and you take care of everything
50 50 seems to be the norm
right
that's just the way that people sort of
set things up so what are you going to
do now you know you're going to say hey
you know hey bill i came across this
bald guy with a beard on youtube and he
said that you should be paying for
everything so i'm just not gonna pay for
[ __ ] now
no i don't i don't think so
you know
okay well i'll keep doing what i'm doing
thank you so much it's nice meeting you
yeah you're welcome see jenny
yeah so like
guys like just to be clear i mean if
you've got a woman that's a stay-at-home
wife a mom she's you know she's making
babies for you that's the sort of
environment
you know that you want to do that in but
but it's always like oh you know we'll
take this information and we'll
repackage it this way because uh i don't
want to be paying for [ __ ] anymore
sometimes man sometimes we go like that
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you